und jetzt das heute journal mit hanna
zimmermann und christian sievers
guten abend in ein 0,5 prozent weniger
zwei bis vier prozent weniger zwölf
prozent weniger die prognosen zur
wirtschaftsleistung dieses landes gehen
weit auseinander aber sie haben eine
gemeinsamkeit positiv klingt keine die
vorhersagen der experten reichen aktuell
von das wäre irgendwie machbar bis zu
warnungen vor einer wirtschaftskrise wie
sie zitat die bundesrepublik seit dem
zweiten weltkrieg nicht erlebt hat klar
ist einfach so weitermachen wie bisher
wird nicht funktionieren dass russland
die für deutschland so wichtigen
gaslieferungen bereits jetzt erheblich
drosselt lässt sich nicht ignorieren und
das hat konkrete folgen für die
industrie und für uns alle dominik
löschmeister
ohne erdgas geht hier nichts 1600 grad
hitze brauchen glas schmelzwannen sie
dürfen nicht stoppen das gas muss weiter
fließen jede vierte in deutschland
verkaufte flasche kommt von der firma
wiegand glas in oberfranken ein
kurzfristiger umstieg auf öl oder strom
ist technisch nicht möglich schlimmste
szenario was ich mir vorstellen kann
wäre das eben von jetzt auf gleich das
erdgas weg ist und wir die wanne neben
mehr unkontrolliert als kontrolliert
herunterfahren der schaden ging in die
hunderte von millionen euro in unserem
fall nicht nur unternehmen in der
glasherstellung haben angst dass erdgas
rationiert oder gestoppt wird chemie-
stahl- und metallindustrie es gibt viele
branchen 37 prozent des gases verbraucht
in deutschland die industrie erst danach
folgen die haushalte mit 31 prozent und
wenn es zu reduktionen kommt und wenn es
zu ganz abschaltungen kommt wird das
zwangsläufig dazu führen dass die
produktionen unsere chemie stoffe
zurückgefahren oder beziehungsweise ganz
abschalten seit einigen tagen pumpt
russland deutlich weniger gas nach
deutschland
im winter könnte es eng werden erst
recht wenn moskau den gashahn komplett
zu drehen würde gas sparen der appell
der politik an industrie und haushalte
doch bisher verlangen gerichtsurteile
von den vermietern 20 bis 22 grad in
mietwohnungen dh man da etwas ändern
wollte die regierung also sozusagen
vorsorglich für den fall der fälle das
sonst andere wohnung gar nicht mehr
versorgt werden könnten mit wärme für
diesen fall müsste dann eine gesetzliche
regelung geschaffen werden dass dann die
temperatur etwas abgesenkt werden kann
rein rechnerisch könnten haushalte mit
jedem grad weniger raumtemperatur rund
sechs prozent heizenergie einsparen ein
möglicher baustein mehr bringen soll bei
der stromerzeugung erdgas durch kohle zu
ersetzen so der plan der regierung das
angesparte gas sollen die speicher
fließen auch eine laufzeitverlängerung
der atomkraftwerke ist wieder in der
diskussion die opposition und auch die
fdp fordern dass
wichtig ist die drei verbliebenen
kernkraftwerke länger laufen zu lassen
das ist ein faktum dass es ein fakt was
der wirtschaftsminister aus meiner sicht
so nicht ignorieren kann es gibt keine
argumente aus rein ideologischen basta
argumenten die kernkraft nicht zu
verlängern zumindest solange sie krise
überwunden ist doch kernkraftwerke
weiterlaufen zu lassen erfordert
sicherheitsüberprüfungen außerdem dauere
die bestellung neuer brennstäbe laut
fachleuten 12 bis 18 monate grüne und
spd lehnen das ab klar war allerdings
auch dass diese debatten um die
verlängerung der atomenergie oder die
rückkehr des frackings dass wir das
ablehnen und dass es keine unterstützung
in der sozialdemokratie findet
angespannt beobachten viele unternehmen
wie russland immer weniger gas liefert
und die preise steigen ohne verzicht
beim gas wird es nicht gehen auch nicht
in den eigenen vier wänden
veronika grimm von der uni erlangen
nürnberg ist eine der wirtschaftsweisen
mitglied des sachverständigenrats sie
berät die bundesregierung ihr fachgebiet
energie frau professorin guten abend
guten abend herr sie das denn viele
szenarien im umlauf aktuell manche lesen
sich geradezu apokalyptische bevor wir
jetzt darauf kommen was zu tun ist für
uns alle lassen sie uns vielleicht erst
mal klar machen was auf dem spiel steht
das extremste szenario vielleicht zu
beginn wenn wir jetzt nichts unternehmen
und das gas weiter gedrosselt wird was
würde das aus ihrer sicht für die
wirtschaft bedeuten
das ist erstmal schwer vorherzusagen die
szenarien berechnet wurden sagen dass
wir einen wirtschaftseinbruch erleiden
würden zwischen 0,5 prozentpunkte und 6
prozentpunkte abschlag auf das
prognostizierte wirtschaftswachstum
05 ist sehr optimistisch 6 ist relativ
pessimistisch irgendwo dazwischen werden
wir liegen der punkt ist dass das gas
wichtig ist für die produktion und je
höher die lücke die dann entsteht bei
einem die verstarb russischen gases
desto bitterer wird es für die
wirtschaft desto mehr produktion muss
eingestellt werden und dafür für diese
situation sollten wir vorsorgen und
jetzt schon dafür sorgen dass diese
lücke die entstehen könnte möglichst
klein wird okay da sind wir beim thema
vorsorgen was müssen wir denn tun damit
es nicht so schlimm kommt vielleicht
beginnen wir zunächst mal mit dem großen
verbrauchern mit der industrie
ja es gibt ganz verschiedene
handlungsfelder es ist ja jetzt ein
aktions mechanismus vorgeschlagen worden
dass es auch der richtige weg man sollte
jetzt unmittelbar gas einsparen auch
jetzt schon obwohl eben dieser
lieferstopp noch gar nicht eingetreten
ist weil das ist ja speicherbar und
alles was wir jetzt speichern das fehlt
und dann im kommenden winter nicht im
kommenden winter der ist besonders
wichtig weil dann beginnt die heizsaison
ein großer teil des gasverbrauchs zur
wärmeerzeugung für die privaten
haushalte genutzt dass es ungefähr 30
prozent am gasverbrauch aber das ist
hauptsächlich im winter der fall und
dafür müssen wir vorsorgen weil einfach
der gasverbrauch im winter viel höher
ist als der gasverbrauch im sommer und
was können wir alle tun die
verbraucherinnen und verbraucher in
deutschland vielleicht auch jetzt schon
bei diesen sommerlichen temperaturen
ja es gibt prinzipiell theoretisch ein
großes potenzial auch im bereich der
wärmeerzeugung einzusparen aber das
problem ist natürlich dass es sehr
kleinteilig jeder selbst das am besten
wo er vielleicht einsparen kann in
einigen mietshäusern ist die
heizungsanlage vielleicht nicht optimal
eingestellt andere sind ohnehin kurz
davor ihre heizungsanlage auszutauschen
und können das vielleicht sogar noch
realisieren trotz der aktuellen
knappheit bei den handwerkern 5 prozent
der gas heizanlagen sind schon über
ihrer lebensdauer also da würde ein
austausch ohnehin anstehen außerdem kann
man natürlich die temperatur
runterregeln also es gibt ganz
vielfältige möglichkeiten und das
reduktionspotenzial des gasverbrauchs
dürfte relativ hoch seinem haus
haushaltsbereich aber es ist eben sehr
schwer zu heben und allein appelle
werden da nicht reichen man könnte hier
mit anreizen arbeiten also prämien
ausschreiben für diejenigen die
besonders viel gas einspeichern im
kommenden winter im vergleich zum
letzten winter und darauf kann man sich
eben auch vorbereiten zum beispiel wenn
man seine heizungsanlage
austauscht oder wenn man seine
heizanlage neu einstellen all diese
möglichkeiten gibt es nehmen wir an
diese anreize kämen und würden auch
wirken nehmen wir auch an dass die
appelle fruchten wäre das dann
handhabbar wie es immer so schön heißt
wäre dieser gas mangel für uns
handhabbar in deutschland ja viele
wissenschaftler haben ja sehr früh
darauf hingewiesen dass man alles daran
setzen sollte eben diese situation zu
erreichen dass ein lieferstopp
tatsächlich handhabbar wäre und man kann
da hinkommen aber es erfordert sehr viel
einiges ist schon geschehen aber auch
nicht alles ich glaube die einführung
der auktionen für die industrie ist
jetzt gut da wird noch mal gespart wo es
denn geht der stark liegt da eben auch
geld auf den tisch damit eingespart wird
bei den haushalten könnte man noch mehr
machen und natürlich muss man auch sehen
dass man gas beschafft um diese lücke
weiter zu schließen und dann ist die
wahrscheinlichkeit dass wir einen
wirklich drastischen wirtschaftseinbruch
vermeiden könnten im falle eines
lieferstopps relativ hoch ok also
vorsichtig optimismus höchster raus bei
ihnen frau grimm die akuten krise
könnten wir also wenn das alles so kommt
und so gut vor gebaut wird vielleicht
auch mit enormen staatshilfen am ende
meistern aber was ist mittelfristig mit
einem energieintensiven
wirtschaftsmodell dass wir hier in
deutschland haben und die preise werden
daher nicht wieder auf das alte niveau
zurückfallen oder das ist richtig wenn
wir uns von russland unabhängig machen
wollen bei der gasversorgung dann werden
wir einen hohen gaspreis auch einen
hohen erdölpreise haben und das ist
natürlich eine belastung für die
wirtschaft in der mittleren frist wir
werden auch nicht so schnell die
erneuerbaren energien ausbauen können
dass wir da relativ schnell durch dieses
tal hindurch kommen also es wird eine
zeit geben wo die energie doch relativ
knapp ist wo wir ersatzbeschaffungen
gewährleisten müssen die gaspreise hoch
sein werden und da ist es natürlich
wichtig dass wir uns gut vorbereiten
auch die verlängerung der drei noch
laufenden atomkraftwerke war ja im
gespräch ich war in der vergangenheit
eigentlich nicht dafür die atomenergie
weiter laufen zu lassen aber unter
diesen rahmenbedingungen ist das
durchaus etwas was man noch mal ganz
genau evaluieren sollte ob das nicht
doch eine möglichkeit ist sagt
professorin monika grimm eine der
wirtschaftsweisen ich danke ihnen ganz
herzlich für das gespräch heute abend
ich danke ihnen und
das gedenken das gespräch haben wir aus
termingründen am abend aufgezeichnet wie
geht's weiter mit der deutschen
wirtschaft dazu auch fragen nachher im
heute-journal update von gundula gause
an den präsidenten des ifo instituts
clemens fuss und als wäre all das nicht
genug an düsteren aussichten kommen
schlechte nachrichten von deutschlands
wichtigstem handelspartner
genaugenommen kommen keine klaren
nachrichten sondern wie häufig in china
muss man sich ein bild aus verschiedenen
indikatoren zusammenstellen und dieses
bild sieht alles andere als rosig aus
die europäischen unternehmen in china
haben heute alarm geschlagen und die
regierung zu einem kurswechsel
aufgerufen bei ihrer rigiden corona
politik aus peking miriam stein
diese zeiten wünscht sich tanzlehrer
romney zurück seit wochen sitzt er in
seiner wohnung in shanghai statt in der
tanzschule zu stehen so geht es vielen
millionen menschen im land mit online
unterricht versuchte er zumindest einen
teil seines geschäfts zu retten
mai unternehmen macht drei monate fast
kein umsatz also mal ich mach ein
bisschen umsatz da sind 30 prozent die
um das die ich normalerweise mache aber
die personalkosten laufen
wie er wissen viele chinesinnen und
chinesen bald nicht mehr von was sie
ihre miete zahlen oder lebensmittel
einkaufen sollen fans am meisten trifft
ist der mittelstand und die kleine
chinesische firmen immerhin 90 prozent
des bruttosozialproduktes hier wir gehen
natürlich schon nach zwei monaten
finanziell die luft aus und es trifft
vor allem die jungen leute mehr als 18
prozent sind arbeitslos
im juli strömt dazu noch eine rekordzahl
von 10.000.000 uni absolventen auf den
arbeitsmarkt
ich hoffe corona ist bald unter
kontrolle und das normale leben kann
wieder beginnen
die partie dauert schon zu lange in
meiner branche mussten viele schließen
es sind die folgen der 0 kokot strategie
präsident jean ping feiert sich als ihr
erfinder er verkauft sie der welt als
überlegenheit des chinesischen systems
nun steht sie für die schwäche des
systems sie lockert er die kontrollen
riskiert er tote denn gerade viele
ältere sind nicht geimpft lockert er
nicht riskiert er weiter schlechte
wirtschaftszahlen sein durchregieren hat
ihn im kampf gegen kuwait stark gemacht
jetzt wird es zum problem
sie sind ping hat sicher persönlich
verantwortlich gezeigt für diese
dynamische kowitz 0 wird strategie das
heißt diese jetzt zu ändern das thema
einer niederlage für ihn persönlich
gleich das willkie verhindern auch auf
kosten der wirtschaft und die folgen
gehen weit über china hinaus lockt downs
und abgeriegelte städte unterbrechen
internationale lieferketten
diese ungewisse auf die wirtschaft auf
die investitionsmöglichkeiten die wir
alle haben und natürlich grenzte china
von der außenwelt ab wegen einzelner
fälle werden stadtteile oder sogar ganze
städte abgeriegelt in dandong an der
grenze zu nordkorea 50 tage lang die
leute wollen nicht nur endlich raus aus
ihren wohnungen sondern auch endlich
wieder geld verdienen
guck das ist mein bankkonto alles bei
null
jahrzehntelang war das volk es gewohnt
dass die partei aufschwung und wohlstand
organisiert mit wirtschaftszahlen die
nur eine richtung kannten nach oben
jetzt leidet das volk unter den folgen
der 0 kowitz strategie seines
präsidenten
eine neue stufe der sanktionen gegen
russland zeigt sich heute ganz konkret
in münchen und damit sind wir bei der
nachrichtenübersicht und bei diana
christian die münchner
staatsanwaltschaft hat auf grundlage der
sanktionen die immobilien eines
russischen abgeordneten der duma und
seiner ehefrau beschlagnahmt konkret
geht es um drei wohnungen in münchen und
um das konto für die mietzahlungen laut
staatsanwaltschaft ist es wohl das erste
mal dass in deutschland nicht nur
vermögenswerte eingefroren sondern
tatsächlich immobilien beschlagnahmt
wurden der abgeordnete steht seit dem 23
februar auf der sanktionsliste der eu
zur lage in der ukraine
dort mussten die behörden heute den
verlust einer ortschaft nahe der stadt
sibiu donetsk einräumen laut dem
ukrainischen präsidialamt wurden die
kämpfe im osten und nordosten des landes
noch weiter verstärkt so sollen die
russischen angriffe unter anderem in der
region hilft zugenommen haben
der kreml hat die von litauen ausgehende
beschränkungen des bahn tram sie
zwischen der russischen exklave
kaliningrad und russland als illegal
kritisiert und mit konsequenzen gedroht
kaliningrad liegt an der ostsee zwischen
litauen und polen und hat keine direkte
landverbindung nach russland seit
samstag verbieten die litauischen
behörden den transitverkehr von gütern
die von der eu mit sanktionen belegt
sind dazu gehören unter anderem metalle
wenige tage vor dem eu gipfel haben die
aussenministerinnen und minister der
europäischen union über die
beitrittsperspektive der ukraine und der
republik moldau beraten außenministerin
berbalk unterstützte den vorschlag der
eu-kommission beiden länder den
kandidatenstatus zu verleihen auch der
außenbeauftragte der eu borel zeigte
sich optimistisch die finale
entscheidung darüber treffen die
regierungen der 27 eu-staaten
die israelische regierung will das
parlament auflösen und so den weg für
neuwahlen freimachen damit steuert das
land auf die fünfte parlamentswahl in
dreieinhalb jahren zu laut
ministerpräsident bennett sollen die
abgeordneten der knesset in der
kommenden woche über die pläne abstimmen
sein amt werde vorübergehend
koalitionspartner und außenminister
lafite übernehmen das acht parteien
bündnis dass israel aktuell regiert
hatte im april seine hauchdünne mehrheit
in der knesset verloren
in kolumbien hat mit dem früheren
guerilla-kämpfer gustavo petro erstmal
ein linksgerichteter politiker die
präsidentschaftswahlen gewonnen
ein historisches ereignis in dem
traditionell konservativen land pedro
setzte sich in der stichwahl knapp gegen
seinen gegenkandidaten den
immobilienunternehmer rudolfo hernandez
durch der neue präsident wird einen
wirtschaftlichen und sozialen wandel in
kolumbien einleiten
und jetzt ein rekord über den sich
niemand freuen kann weil er keiner ist
sondern eine schande für diese welt für
uns alle aktuell sind 100 millionen
menschen auf der flucht das ist die
größte zahl an vertriebenen die jemals
registriert wurde es ist eine zahl die
kaum wirklich fassbar ist aber
vielleicht haben sie ja in der letzten
zeit an einem deutschen bahnhof zum
beispiel mal eine familie etwa aus der
ukraine getroffen deren leben jetzt
platz finden muss in einer reisetasche
und ein paar plastiktüten die unterwegs
sind in eine ungewisse zukunft
das sind 34 menschen von 100 millionen
heute ist weltflüchtlingstag damit
wollen die vereinten nationen erinnern
an die die alles aufgeben mussten was
mal ihr zuhause war auch an die an die
kaum noch jemand denkt obwohl sie in
einem der größten flüchtlingslager der
welt leben im norden von kenia susan von
lojewski war dort
wasser irgendwo ist geschäftsmann er
betreibt einen wertstoffhof im
flüchtlingscamp akuma nordkenia das
plastik verkauft er an inder und
chinesen yan kripo hat 500 mitarbeiter
47 davon in vollzeit er ist ein
wohlhabender mann könnte sich vieles
leisten
doch weil der 33-jährige selbst
flüchtlinge aus dem kongo ist ist er
gezwungen weiter in kuba zu leben
puma ist der ort an dem flüchtlinge
leben müssen aber es ist auch ein ort
für geschäfte dort wo es geschäfte gibt
sind wir berechtigt zu leben aber es
gibt vorschriften
rund 160.000 menschen leben in kuba noch
einmal 70.000 in angrenzenden camp
kaluga kenia erkennt sie als flüchtlinge
an die staatsangehörigkeit aber bekommen
sie nicht sabine schuler lebt mit ihren
drei kindern seit sechs jahren in kaluga
ihr mann wurde vor ihren augen von
südsudanesischen milizen erschossen ihr
ältester sohn verschwand um die anderen
kinder zu retten ist sie geflohen
wir kommen gerade so zu recht manchmal
kann man sogar ohne essen schlafen sie
sehen ja im moment haben wir kein wasser
zu trinken wir kommen gerade so über die
runden
etwa 13 euro zahlt die un pro flüchtling
pro monat zusätzlich stellt die
grundnahrungsmittel wie mais mail und
linsen zurück in den südsudan kann
sabinas familie wegen der anhaltenden
konflikte nicht vielleicht nie mehr ich
einen besseren ort für die ausbildung
seiner kinder finden kann dann ist es
das was ich mir wünsche damit sie eine
bessere ausbildung bekommen und ein
besseres leben führen können zumindest
nicht so wie ich
viele der menschen die in kalkutta oder
kalorien leben sind schon dort geboren
sie kennen nichts anderes seit jahren
verhandelt die un mit der regierung
kenias über eine dauerhafte lösung
bessere integration doch gerade jetzt
vor den wahlen im august macht kenia
keine zugeständnisse
wir sprechen hier von einer zweiten und
dritten generation von flüchtlingen die
im lager geboren und in china
aufgewachsen sind
was bedeutet dass sie kenia island
ansehen
wir sind mit der internationalen
gemeinschaft im gespräch um eine
friedenslösung für ihre heimatländer zu
finden und mit der kenianischen
regierung um sie in die kenianische
gesellschaft in der sie aufgewachsen
sind zu integrieren
eine schnelle lösung aber wird es nicht
geben um so lange keine gefunden ist
gibt es auch keine perspektive für die
vielen kinder und jugendlichen die hier
aufwachsen sie können nicht zurück in
die heimat ihrer familien und sie dürfen
das lager nicht verlassen sie sind
gefangen im flüchtlingscamp
akuma auf swahili bedeutet das so viel
wie nirgendwo
jetzt zurück zu den sorgen bei uns hanna
die täglich größer werden die inflation
steigt die menschen in deutschland
können sich immer weniger leisten und
die ig metall fordert angesichts dessen
jetzt ein kräftiges lohnplus und zwar
für die rund 3,8 millionen beschäftigten
der metall und elektroindustrie valerie
haller an frankfurt was genau will die
gewerkschaft in der nächsten tarifrunde
durchsetzen und welche probleme werden
dabei gesehen also eben wie schon
erwähnt einen kräftigen lohnaufschlag
will die ig metall die ja die größte
deutsche gewerkschaft ist und ihre
forderung hat also entsprechende
signalwirkung auch für andere branchen
und da befürchten manche ökonomen dass
das der beginn einer lohn-preis-spirale
sein könnte also dass sich die
preissteigerungen und lohnerhöhungen
gegenseitig hochschaukeln was am ende
eine noch höhere inflation zur folge
hätte die ig metall sieht das anders
nach mehreren jahren zurückhaltung und
angesichts hoher inflationsraten
empfiehlt der vorstand sieben bis acht
prozent mehr lohn bei einer laufzeit von
ca fünf monaten das sei ein beitrag zur
stabilisierung des konsums die
auftragsbücher der unternehmen seien
voll wie nie auch machten die firmen
gute gewinne die arbeitgeber von
gesamtmetall zu der auch die
autoindustrie und der maschinenbau
gehören werden die forderung hingegen
als verantwortungslos und verweisen auf
hohe rohstoff- und energiekosten und
unsicherheiten durch corona und den
ukraine krieg auch könne von guter
ertragslage keine rede sein noch ist es
nur ein vorschlag über den die
tarifbezirke nun beraten müssen im
herbst dann beginnen die
tarifverhandlungen
sie könnten hart werden angesichts einer
inflationsrate von aktuell fast acht
prozent wird es für die arbeitgeberseite
schwer deutlich weniger anzubieten und
für die gewerkschaften wiederum geht es
auch darum in krisenzeiten zu zeigen
wofür man eine arbeitnehmervertretung
braucht danke valerie nach frankfurt
bei bundesweiten razzien wegen haas
kommentaren im internet hat die polizei
heute die wohnungen von 75 verdächtigen
durchsucht dabei konnten 180 datenträger
wie smartphones oder laptops
sichergestellt werden die durchsuchungen
sind eine reaktion auf zahlreiche
hassbotschaften die nach der tötung von
zwei polizisten im rheinland pfälzischen
kusel verbreitet wurden insgesamt wird
gegen 150 beschuldigte ermittelt zum
beispiel wegen beleidigungen oder der
billigung von straftaten
die weltkunstausstellung documenta in
kassel sieht sich ein weiteres mal mit
antisemitismus-vorwürfen konfrontiert
nun wurden teile eines kunstwerks
abgedeckt im zentrum steht ein
großflächiges banner eines indonesischen
künstlerkollektivs darauf ist unter
anderem ein soldat mit schweins gesicht
zu sehen dieser trägt einen davidstern
und einen helm mit der aufschrift mossad
am abend entschieden geschäftsführung
und künstlerische leitung gemeinsam mit
dem kollektiv die betreffenden stellen
zu verdecken
die lage bei den beiden waldbränden nahe
treuenbrietzen und beelitz in
brandenburg hat sich durch starken regen
deutlich entspannt die feuer seien unter
kontrolle
die bewohnerinnen und bewohner der
evakuierten ortschaften konnten in ihre
häuser zurückkehren die feuerwehr ist
aber weiterhin im einsatz hauptsorge
sind glutnester die neue brände
entfachen könnten so die behörden
bei der schwimm wm in budapest hat anna
elend über 100 meter brust die
silbermedaille gewonnen mit nur fünf
hundertstelsekunden rückstand schlug die
20 jährige hinter der italienerin plato
an bronze ging an die litauerin mai lud
t es ist die erste wm medaille einer
deutschen schwimmerinnen auf dieser
strecke seit 31 jahren und
jetzt ein bild nur und schon läuft bei
uns allen ein film ab die kinoindustrie
lebt seit jeher auch vom mythos
vielleicht sogar vor allem vom mythos
wie dieser mythos entstanden ist gerade
durch die fotografie das zeigen wir
ihnen jetzt es ist eine reise ins herz
von amerikas traumfabrik dort wo
illusion geschaffen wird und irgendwann
nichts mehr ist wie es scheint für diese
reise müssen wir nicht zum pazifik
fliegen es reicht eine tour an die spree
stephan merseburger nimmt uns mit
ist der nicht cool und ist sie nicht
schön clint eastwood julia roberts
anthony hopkins und cd die wir allesamt
meisterhaft porträtiert über 300 fotos
von 14 künstlern zeigt die hollywood
ausstellung der helmut newton stiftung
im berliner museum für fotografie die
zeitreise durch die traumfabrik beginnt
mit den großen diven der studios greta
garbo und joan crawford stilvolle fotos
die in magazinen erscheinen und den
mythos hollywood befeuern
pr aufnahmen wenn man so will von den
studiobossen initiiert sind bilder die
die fans lieben es sind bilder wo aber
auch die eigene fotografische
handschrift derjenigen die sie machen
schon rüber kommt und zwar bis heute
rüberkommt auch 100 jahre später ohne
die fotografie wäre der glamour
hollywoods gar nicht erst entstanden
nach dem zweiten weltkrieg rücken die
dreharbeiten in das zentrum des
interesses marilyn monroe auf dem set
des klassikers the misfits nicht
gesellschaftsfähig
oder jack nicholson und faye dunaway
beim making of von roman polanskis
kultfilm chinatown der im san fernando
valley gedreht wurde hier produziert die
pornoindustrie hunderte filme am tag
auch die dunklen seiten beleuchtet die
ausstellung haslers männliche
prostituierte rund um den santa monica
boulevard und verlierer der glitzerwelt
die auf der straße landen
es gehört alles zusammen und in
hollywood es gibt eben diesen glamour
und viel licht aber auch einigen
schatten und wie sich in letzter zeit
entwickelt hat mit sehr sehr vielen
obdachlosen
das kann hier natürlich auch nicht
visuell fehlen natürlich wird in der
newton stiftung auch der große helmut
ausführlich gewürdigt die winter
verbrachte er seit den 80er jahren in l
e er hatte sie alle vor der linse auch
jack nicholson und vätern
elizabeth taylor aufgenommen im jahre
sie trägt wertvollen schmuck sie ist
gestylt aber eigentlich der auf das
aufnahmedatum verrät uns dass dreht sie
gar keine filme mehr und es ist alles
illusion juden zeigt uns die illusion
und zeigt uns gleichzeitig einen blick
auf diesen star als da und das ist eine
unglaublich tolle ambivalenz in seiner
bildsprache
der meister der ironie zeigt daryl
hannah mit gleich zwei oscars
tatsächlich bekommen hat sie bislang
keinen
die zukunft sehen die macher der
ausstellung übrigens alles andere als
glanzlos und verblasst dieses spezielle
licht in allen hat ja immer noch seinen
reiz und außerdem die amerikaner eher
finden sich ja immer neu
damit verabschieden wir uns von ihnen
und wünschen ihnen jetzt noch einen
schönen abend
[Musik]
guten abend in einigen teilen
deutschlands ist es zurzeit
außergewöhnlich hier in diesen rot
eingefärbten gebieten zum beispiel in
sachsen anhalt oder in brandenburg eine
dürre wie sie ende juni etwa alle 50
jahre einmal vorkommt wenn sie wissen
wollen wie viel regen da wohl fehlt es
werden wohl einige hundert liter pro
quadratmeter seien natürlich ist das
örtlich sehr unterschiedlich was jetzt
nötig wäre ist der regen aber der kommt
vorerst nicht dieses tief zieht nämlich
nach osten ab und die luft wird jetzt
von südwesten schüler das bedeutet aber
eher kräftige schauer auch mal kräftige
gewitter und nicht den dauerregen den
wir so nötig brauchen heute nacht fällt
etwas regen hier an der ostsee und an
den alpen gibt es einzelne gewitter
sonst ist es klar zum teil weil es
richtig kalt im sauerland sinken die
werte bis 4 grad sonst sind es so 11 bis
6 grad und hier im chiemgau oder auch
richtung oberrhein bleibt es bilder mit
15 bis 13 grad am morgen liegen die
höchsttemperaturen bei 19 bis 25 grad im
südwesten sind es 28 bis 32 grad das
wird ein meist sonniger dienstag mit nur
wenigen quellwolken nachmittags
allerdings können sich dann einige
gewitter entwickeln wie zb hier im
schwarzwald
so ähnlich geht es auch weiter im süden
ist es eher schön es gibt einige
gewitter im norden ist es sonnig und
kühler und unwetter drohen erst wieder
am freitag guten abend